soy académico investigador de la
universidad sãntomas estudió los efectos
de los estilos de vida en la salud de la
población y hoy vengo a invitarlos a
todos ustedes a un viaje que
difícilmente podrán olvidar
así que abróchense sus cinturones
pónganse cómodos y aquí haremos una
aventura por el tiempo desde las
cavernas hasta las oficinas del día de
hoy para reflexionar sobre que nos
estamos enfermando están preparados
vamos
haremos nuestra primera parada nuestra
primera escala de este viaje
en el paleolítico
imaginemos que estamos en esta época en
la cual los primeros hombres vivían las
cavernas
y corrían libres por la sabana
imaginemos que el lenguaje no es una
barrera para la comunicación
quienes diríamos
qué conversaríamos con ellos
podría ser una excelente oportunidad
para saber cómo vivían en las cavernas
pero también podría servir para nosotros
contarles cómo vivimos en el futuro
sentados
en un tronco frente una fogata
imaginemos que iniciamos una
conversación
les comienzo a hablar sobre la
tecnología sobre los aviones sobre los
rascacielos son los trenes de alta
velocidad sobre internet la computación
los celulares todo un mundo muy moderno
y tecnológico
en algún momento la conversación deriva
hacia los estilos de vida les hablo
sobre la medicina moderna les digo que
hay un montón de medicamentos para poder
combatir muchas de las enfermedades
cotidianas
para el dolor de cabeza para el dolor de
estómago para la inflamación para las
alergias
les comento aquí ya la gente casi no
muere de infecciones y las grandes
placas están controladas
que en el futuro ya no arrancamos de los
tigres dientes de sable los que les
generan un gran alivio
después la conversación deriva la
alimentación
les comentó que existen supermercados en
los cuales se puede encontrar una gran
abundancia de alimentos podemos
encontrar cereales tubérculos
pescado así como también podemos
encontrar papas fritas bebidas
chocolates dulces etcétera
la fruta y la verdura con sólo apretar
un botón o caminar unos pasos podemos
acceder a ella
les comento que el agua viene
embotellada
evitó hablar de marcas pero me resulta
difícil
no se pueden imaginar el mundo que les
espera con la boca abierta me mira no se
pueden imaginar los restaurantes los
supermercados las panaderías
en algún momento de la conversación me
entusiasmo y les comienza a hablar sobre
la industria de la agronomía y de la
agricultura les hablo sobre los
alimentos procesados congelados
enlatados y un momento uno de ellos me
interrumpe y me preguntan disculpa
después de todo lo que me has contado
cuáles son los principales problemas que
tienen ustedes
y que se enferman
de que muere la gente
excelente pregunta
están preocupados después de todas las
maravillas que les comenté
sobre de que nosotros podríamos
enfermarnos de que podríamos morir
qué me dirían ustedes
lo primero que se me viene a la cabeza
es hablar de sobre
la epidemia del asentar ismo de la
obesidad que existe en el mundo lo que
le resulta difícil de entender por sus
cuerpos tonificados y delgados los
comienzo a hablar sobre las enfermedades
crónicas que aquejan el mundo
como la diabetes de
sobre la demencia sobre el cáncer
ellos no conocen ninguno de estos tipos
de enfermedades por lo que me preguntan
qué es la demencia que es la depresión
cómo se produce la diabetes cómo se
produce la enfermedades cardíacas
intentó explicarle de la forma lo más
simple posible toda esta terminología
médica pero me miran con mucha
incertidumbre y con muchas dudas
no pueden creerlo
qué pasó que se había pintado un mundo
hermoso y moderno y de un momento a otro
todo se derrumba mostrándole las causas
de las enfermedades más terribles frente
a sus ojos que morir de una infección o
morir las fauces de un depredador
solo el hecho de pensar
y van a tener una muerte larga
prolongada y dolorosa desparecidas
partos
intento explicarles que en cierta medida
las enfermedades degenerativas y
crónicas son producto de una vida más
larga
y no me lo cree comienzan a reírse
y de repente yo tampoco me lo creo
si bien es cierto que tenemos una es un
hecho que tenemos una esperanza de día
más larga no deja de ser cierto que
podríamos tener una mejor calidad de
vida sin enfermedades que son totalmente
prevenibles
me quiero reflexionando solo que
conversamos y decido despedirme de mis
antepasados de nuestros antepasados para
seguir este viaje en busca de las
posibles causas a los estilos de vida
que llevamos actualmente
vamos de nuevo de viaje
vamos
y vivir
la siguiente escala segunda escala los
quiero llevar a inglaterra del siglo 19
en la cuna de la revolución industrial
en esta época se generaron el mayor
conjunto transformaciones económicas
sociales y tecnológicas en la historia
de la humanidad desde el neolítico la
revolución industrial marcó un punto de
inflexión en la historia modificando
para bien o para mal la mayoría de los
aspectos de la vida cotidiana de las
personas a modo de ejemplo la producción
de la agricultura y de la incipiente
industria aumentaron exponencialmente a
la vez que disminuyó el tiempo de
producción
en este momento se generó el inicio de
la transición que acabaría con siglos
del uso de la mano de obra de tipo
manual y tracción animal para ser
reemplazada
por la empresa para ser reemplazada por
máquinas que harían la producción a
nivel industrial y permitirían el
traslado de personas y de mercadería
decidió acercarme a una de las
industrias como muchas de las que haya
en esa época para intentar conversar con
una de las personas que trabajan en él
le comento que vengo del futuro que no
tenga miedo que lo único que quiero es
conversar con él y saber cómo vive en
esta época
imagina solo como sería nuevamente esta
conversación a diferencia de la primera
conversación yo intento tomar la
iniciativa y utilizar las preguntas
les pregunto en este caso esta persona
cómo vive en esta época
él me comenta que junto a su familia
vivía en el campo y se trasladaron a la
ciudad el a trabajar en la industria
me comenta que tiene extensas horas de
trabajo
me comenta que a diferencia del trabajo
que tenía en el campo el cual era muy
físico en esta industria tiene que pasar
muchas horas sentado y cree que está
comenzando a ganar peso
lo miro trabajando a él ya sus
compañeros
y a simple vista el panorama no me
parece muy diferente a cómo se vería una
empresa en el futuro
preocupado es me pregunta y ustedes
de que se enferman
se repite la pregunta
de que mueren en el futuro
antes de responderle lo mismo que le
respondí a nuestro antepasado del
paleolítico
y en su segundo
y le comento que en términos de
diagnóstico ha avanzado mucho
la tecnología ha llegado a todos los
ámbitos hay una mayor cobertura de salud
y gracias a los conocimientos de la
genética incluso se pueden hacer
tratamientos individualizados
pero
en la actualidad existe mucha epidemia
de obesidad y sedentarismo
preocupado por la prestación
decido reiniciar el viaje y hacer
nuestra última escala
vamos de nuevo
porque creo que en cierta medida en esta
época es descubierto
el origen de los estilos de vida que
llevamos en la actualidad nos han
llevado a generar las enfermedades
crónicas
nuestra última escala estamos en el
chile de hoy estamos en la actualidad
y les pregunto
chile es muy diferente en razones
estilos de vida como son otros países
son occidentalizados
chile es muy diferente a lo que
escucharon en la conversación que
ocurría doscientos años atrás
intento recordar como vivíamos 30 o 40
años atrás donde la mayoría de los que
estamos acá éramos niños
los estilos de vida eran muy diferentes
en esa época
las calles estaban llenas de niños
jugando
en los recreos todos corrían y jugaban
para todos lados
es más esta es la época en la que más
recuerdo del colegio
en las casas las comidas eran familiares
se sentaban en torno a la mesa comían
comidas caseras no comía chatarra y los
fin de semana estaban destinados a
paseos familiares que pasó porque en tan
corto tiempo no sólo en chile sino en el
resto del mundo los estilos de vida
cambiaron tanto
las explicaciones son multifactoriales
pero lo que es un hecho es esto
según la última encuesta nacionales de
salud en chile
el 87 por ciento de la población se
declara sedentaria
sólo el 15 por ciento de la población
dice que come las 5 frutas y verduras al
día que son la alimentación recomendable
para el ministro de salud para una
alimentación saludable estos junto a
otros factores de riesgo y algunas
variables sociales y culturales ha
generado que más del 70 por ciento de la
población tenga malnutrición por exceso
eso significa que 40% tiene malnutrición
y más del 30% tiene obesidad
un 27% de la población indica a ser
sospechosa de hipertensión y cerca de un
12 3% de la población sospechosa de
diabetes
esto es un hecho
existe bastante evidencia y consenso a
nivel científico que la inactividad de
sentar ismo son perjudiciales en la
salud
a modo de ejemplo solo les pongo algunos
artículos
ya se sabe que las personas en
comparación las físicamente activas con
las que no realizan la cantidad mínima
de actividad física recomendada para la
salud por la organización mundial de la
salud ósea 150 minutos de actividad
física a la semana moderado vigorosa
tienen mayores niveles de obesidad de
hipertensión de glicemia de centro
metabólico etc etc
existe una forma fácil y barata de
contrarrestar los efectos negativos de
la inactividad de senderismo
es el ejercicio
también existe bastante evidencia y aquí
sólo muestro algunas de ellas que
indican que el ejercicio podría ser
contrarrestar los efectos negativos del
sedentarismo
que las personas que practican ejercicio
físico podrían tener menor probabilidad
de tener factores de riesgo
cardiovascular menor probabilidad
diabetes y menor probabilidad de
obesidad
cuando chico me gustaba mucho jugar en
las calles pasaba corriendo aprendí
mucho de las prácticas de deportes
colectivos y en cierta medida creo que
eso me motivó de adulto a estudiar los
efectos de la actividad física en la
salud de la población
en términos simples podríamos decir que
el ejercicio es la intervención
costo-beneficio más eficaz que existe en
la actualidad para contrarrestar y
prevenir la mayoría de las enfermedades
que nos aquejan en la vejez
algunos autores lo llaman una
polipíldora
por qué le llaman polipíldora porque
bien prescritas y bien dosificada es
capaz de contrastar y prevenir
prácticamente todas las enfermedades
provocadas por qué estilos de vida
insanos
nuestros antepasados no tenían claro
y nos heredaron nos heredaron un
precioso regalo sus genes nuestros genes
nuestros genes están diseñados para que
estemos en constante movimiento y no lo
estamos aprovechando al contrario ese
precioso regalo que nos han entregado lo
estamos desperdiciando
hemos hecho un paseo desde las cavernas
pasando por la revolución industrial
para llegar hasta los piscinas de la
actualidad
y cada vez más empatiza con la cara de
duda e incertidumbre de mis compañeros
antepasados de nuestros antepasados
cuando les explicaba las enfermedades
que tenemos en la actualidad en el
futuro para ellos
y en mi cabeza ronda la pregunta que me
hicieron la gente del paleolítico y de
la revolución industrial
de que nos estamos muriendo y que nos
estamos enfermando
en la actualidad
podemos decir
que los estilos de vida que nosotros
llevamos en gran medida nos permiten
elegir de qué no se vamos a enfermar o
de que vamos a morir
qué opinan ustedes
cómo y cuánto quieren vivir
la elección es suya
[Aplausos]